hey guys so first of all I just want to
say I'm really sorry for taking so long
to get this video to you it's been long
overdue I apologize some things have
gotten in the way of me filming it but
now I'm here to talk about my QA answers
part two let's get right off the bat
into the first question
Keith O'Neil asks when doing reviews do
you write down stuff you think while the
movie is playing or are the things you
say in videos just off the top of your
head and making it up as you go along
it's a little bit of both see I don't
write during the movies I don't know I
do know some people who write during
movies I can't do that because I've
actually find that it's just first off I
can't actually see the paper I'm like in
the dark and I'm like trying to write it
but it's not just that I find it's very
distracting for me to be to try to write
during a movie like I will be writing
something like whoo that was so cool
and then I'll miss something that
happens and I'm like oh crap I just
missed that a lot of my videos are
improv style but I definitely think up
kind of a structure in my head before
going to actually do the review I kind
of think up a general this is what I
want to say these are the points I want
to make and then I do kind of expound
upon them through improv from JW he sent
me a very nice message but his question
was I was wondering when you're not
parroting or you know like doing like a
parody skit of something you know like
making up a short film that kind of
parodies another movie what do you like
to write and if you ever made it in
Hollywood what kind of movies would you
like to make are there any ideas that
you've been floating around in your head
that you consider your dream project
I'll make a little announcement here I'm
currently saving it to go to film school
there's a Cleveland Film School that I
can get a degree and film directing and
that's kind of a goal of mine and it's
been a goal for a long time I know that
some of the best directors in Hollywood
like Spielberg and Scorsese they never
actually went to film school I still
think it would definitely be in today's
day and age would be a good help and a
good learning experience for me but if I
did ever get to direct real films in
Hollywood I definitely have some very
personal tales I'd like to tell that I
won't get into but I also have a lot of
fun popcorn pulpy entertainment kind of
movies that I would love to make as well
from Gus Babbington hey Chris as you
know I've been a longtime viewer since
2007 Wow
thank you sir really thank you always
been a fan of your films and what you
come up with next was just curious do
you have any fun plans for a new short
film anytime in the near
I do have an idea in my head of a short
film that I want to make this summer
it's kind of about this one guy who's on
a revenge path and that's all I really
want to say but it's it's been in my
head for a long time
it's very City nightlife inspired very
film noir ish and I would love to be
able to do that at some point thank you
Gus I've seen your comments forever
you've been amazing if you might
actually be my first ever fan slash
viewers so thank you that's I I don't
even know what to say to I I'm
constantly amazed by the fact that
anyone watches my videos so thank you
from Christian I'll make this nice and
simple in your opinion what are your
thoughts of Daniel day-lewis his
performance and there will be blood
incredible one of the best performances
ever given by an actor I had the blu-ray
over there it's one of those movies
where you just you don't actually see
the actor you just see this guy he is
that guy and as you watch the movie
there is no actor there it's just that's
a guy and that's sort of the best
compliment that you can give an actor is
to say I did not see you in that role
you were just that man and he was and
it's one of the best performances ever I
love that movie
Marshall Abbott sent me a few questions
he wants to know what is my favorite
episode of Spongebob um I do enjoy the
older episodes of Spongebob my favorite
was called just one bite it's this
episode where Squidward becomes addicted
to Krabby Patties but he's afraid to
tell Spongebob and it has some of the
funniest little animations in there
Squidward's face when he's like does
this look on char to you and he's like
get this really close-up this animated
version of his face just like really
upset and everything just a lot of fun
moments in the episode no Squidward I
meant good for you so oh you'd also like
to know do you like survival horror
games if so which are your favorite
definitely the first Resident Evil I
loved Resident Evil 4 as well I've
played other survival horror games but
none of them have really got to be that
fun as Resident Evil was so definitely
those games Josh Logan wants to know I
know you're a fan of more retro games
like Zelda and Goldeneye but do you ever
get a chance to play newer games like
Assassin's Creed or Skyrim
yes I do I have a ps3 I have a Wii I'm
probably going to get the ps4 when it
comes out and I do like to play video
games more and as I made an announcement
recently I'd like to start reviewing
them more just because I want to tell
guys my thoughts on video games and I
may not be as skilled a video game
reviewer as some people who've been
doing it for longer than me but I will
try to learn more about it I'm currently
playing Metal Gear Solid 2 on the HD
collection I've played the game before
but I got the HD collection for ps3 and
I want to play two three apiece Walker
in HD because the four Metal Gear Solid
games I consider my favorite video game
ever I'd also just beat heavy rain that
game is immersive and incredible and
yeah heavy rain is one of the most
cinematic game experiences I've ever had
Jonah Schwartz asked me hey Chris where
does the intro / outro music come from
in your videos um I actually made that
myself I can post it with sound clips
through GarageBand so that I could you
know not be hit with some sort of
copyright thing it's entirely my own
composition so it comes from me I guess
Bill Thompson asked me a few questions
he liked to know have I ever seen Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang fan tastic movie I have
the blu-ray as well for that love head
movie so funny directed by Shane Black
written by Shane Black starring Robert
Downey jr. Val Kilmer and that's one of
the things that gives me a lot of hope
for Iron Man 3 is Shane Black's
inclusion in it with Robert Downey jr.
again pretty cool movie definitely
looking forward to Ironman 3 from while
Al Jaber I I'm almost positive I screwed
that up entirely I apologize he'd like
to know what are my thoughts on Stanley
Kubrick he mentioned that I haven't
really talked much about him as a person
from what I understand Stanley Kubrick
wasn't exactly the greatest guy he was I
guess a little hard to work with but his
films are immaculate I mean it's like
when you watch one of his movies it's
just stunning the amount of visual
ingenuity that go into his movies and
the obvious amount of planning that just
went to this insane degree of being able
to plan each movie that some of his
movies took years to make I mean Eyes
Wide Shut basically shut down Tom
Cruise's career for like two years
because of how long that movie took to
make he's very meticulous he's a little
difficult to work with from what I've
understood in the past and he wasn't
really nicest guy but his movies are
insanely well made from Daniel s sorry
man I honestly can't pronounce that I
would butcher it and I apologize are you
going to co-host the 2013 year reviewers
Awards I'm actually going to be going to
in a couple days actually and I'm going
to go on the schmoes know podcast with
Jeremy Jones and John Flickinger the
flick pick and the schmoes of course and
we're all going to actually be there in
LA for the filming of the your viewers
Awards and that's pretty cool I'm
excited about that and I'm really
looking forward to that I'm actually
going to make one more announcement
video about this as well but in case you
don't get a chance to see that video I'm
going to be in LA in a few days and I'm
excited for it and yeah your viewers
awards man I'm pumped from Michael
Rockwell finally and named that I can
just pronounce he would like to know
what are my thoughts on Girl Meets World
the new spin-off show - Boy Meets World
and he'd like to know was I fan growing
up and if it meant anything to me yeah I
watched like every episode of that show
growing up it was like a thing with me I
would watch it every day after school it
was on this one channel to get what a
channel was about watch it every day and
I just got so like all into that world
and it was really funny actually and
even though it was kind of heart felt a
little like more cheesy and sometimes
than it could have been it was just it
was actually a pretty well-written show
I watched a few episodes of it recently
again I got some of the season DVDs and
that show was actually pretty funny I
don't think it was just because I was a
kid and I grew up with it it was
actually a pretty well made show and as
for this spin-off of course I'm afraid
you know you're afraid of it it's it's
not going to be the same because you're
older now I just hope that it's not some
mindless thing and I've read danielle
fishel Bluest Eye Center named Danielle
officials or topanga's she moved like a
giant open letter about it how she
really they all feel really close to it
and they don't want to ruin it and they
feel just as sacred about it as a lot of
its fans do so hopefully it'll be good
from Bradley hangsen he has a few
questions for me he'd like to know what
are some of my favorite guilty pleasures
The Wicker Man with Nicolas Cage that is
such a horrible movie but my word is it
hilarious what's in the bag a shark or
something just you know what movie is so
bad Batman and Robin that is an
absolutely horrible movie and but it is
so funny though could you view it as a
comedy it's frickin hilarious
the room of course is a classic one
right there the room oh my word I
actually penned a word based off these
type of movies
hilarious 'ti they are such an atrocity
that they are hilarious he'd also like
to know do you know what a brony is I
unfortunately do it's a man who likes
the My Little Pony cartoon and I don't
I've seen it okay here's the honest
truth my girlfriend loves that show and
she has forced me to watch it and it's
not awful it actually is not awful it's
sort of funny I'm not a brony though I'm
not Richard M asks me I've seen about 50
of your videos now I've noticed they're
very clear I would just like to know
what microphone on camera are you use I
use a Nikon d50 100 and my microphone is
the rode videomic you can get that off
Amazon the thing about my videos though
it's not just a camera you have to be
sure to export it in at least 720 HD so
that if you want to choose 720 HD then
you can get the clarity because even if
you have a great camera you got to make
sure the settings for exporting your
video are good so that for you to
understand the video and you can find a
lot of tutorial videos on YouTube for
that Jay a v8 $4.99 would like to know
that's the name I have do you prefer
movie shot in film or digital I think
that's a great question there's a really
good documentary I saw called
side-by-side hosted by Keanu Reeves that
is entirely about that and I got a say
look digital has great things about it
for one you can actually see the film as
you are making your movie you can then
immediately view it on a monitor and see
if it looks well when you're shooting
the film you can't do that you have to
look at dailies and there are certain
benefits to both however film just has
this crispness and this almost
imperfection about it that somehow makes
it have more life than digital does and
although certain films look fantastic
digitally and there's no like you know
Skyfall for instance I believe was shot
digital there's no problem with it I
think that film has a life that digital
won't necessarily have but they both
definitely have their benefits my good
buddy Allen Gunn would like to know mini
movies now regarded as classics received
mixed / negative reviews when they first
came out what are some movies that have
come out somewhat recently and received
mixed lash negative reviews that you
feel will be looked upon more favorably
in the coming years
well I think that prometheus is one of
those movie
I truly do I think that that's one of
the movies that was harmed by hype and
initial reaction and thoughts about has
to be like alien has to be like aliens I
think that twenty years from now that
movie will be regarded a little bit more
highly the problem is that with the
internet generation everything is like
set in stone it's like oh it came out
and this is it's great on Rotten
Tomatoes and this is it's great on IMDB
and this is it's great on Metacritic
well twenty years from now it's going to
have that same grade so you know I guess
it's just that way when psycho came out
in the 60s and people were like whoa I
don't know about this there was no
rotten tomatoes there was no IMDB there
was no like set in stone grade that it
was given to certain places even though
that's just people's opinions they
didn't have that back then nowadays it's
regarded as a classic and everyone's
like Oh psycho is so brilliant and it is
but that's because now you can look back
on the time that has come since then and
you can see how inspirational it was at
the time it was just psycho and this is
this is I don't know about this one this
is a little this is a little too much
nowadays it's PETA's differently but
unfortunately there wasn't any internet
back then but I think the internet
really has a big pool on how people
initially feel about a movie because if
people recognize that all these people
are starting to feel the same way about
a movie and I'm going to jump in with
the crowd now because I look at all
these people hating on it
I think the internet definitely has an
influence on it and Twitter and social
media for sure unfortunately it's true
it really does have influence on culture
and people's thoughts on things and I
really think that certain movies would
be looked at differently in the coming
years if it wasn't for things like the
internet and hype and stuff like that so
guys thank you so much for sending me
all these questions I apologize once
again for getting part two a little bit
overdue but thanks so much for all your
wonderful questions it really blew my
mind the response that was given and it
continues to blow my mind that you guys
enjoy watching my videos and I just I
thank you you know I just a guy who
loves movies and I enjoy talking about
them I don't really think much of myself
but the fact that you guys do does mean
a lot to me and I really appreciate that
I really
do and I'm constantly surprised by it so
thanks very much and I'll be back very
soon in fact tonight I'm going to go see
the last stand with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and as always guys if you
like this video then you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]